the pandemic has forced various
businesses to change in the last
year right well that includes a place on
sahara near maryland
in the historic commercial center 8 news
now reporter kristen drummond joins us
live in the newsroom tonight
with more on how the owners got creative
in their plans for expansion
kristen sasha the vegas room opened last
june
it's a supper club that was originally
tended to be a catering hall but
the pandemic forced the owners to adjust
their plans which
led to creating a platform for
performers to work
the venue invites people to sit down for
an intimate brunch or dinner
with local entertainers a new business
plan following the temporary shutdown
last
march the owners did not intend to
create a supper club but
they adapted to the situation and
noticed a need among the local
entertainment community
following so many out of work the vegas
room started
live streaming shows and then offering a
space for performers
once the governor eased restrictions
it's a platform of hope
for so many talented people in this city
to come
and do what they do best there are some
entertainers here
who sometimes find it difficult to not
only
not during coveted times but find it
difficult to find places to play here
after finding success the last few
months the owners plan to open a larger
supper club called the nevada room
a few doors down as well as a piano bar
bistro soon
the owners want to continue focusing on
local performers
entertaining guests now coming up at six
how the owners are finding success and
a singer talks to me about the support
received from the vegas room during this
time
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now